so we got Xbox game pass core coming
this September it looks like gold is
becoming Game Pass core starting
September 14th with a new selection of
games going into Game Pass core it's the
evolution of Xbox Live Gold core will
give players access to Advanced
multiplayer and a collection of over 25
games to play
um with exclusive member deals offering
9.99 per month or 60 per year so they
list all the titles and then they go
through the plans and there's obviously
the core plan at 9.99 there's the
console playing at 10.99 the PC plan at
9.99 and the ultimate plan which is kind
of like the all-in-one Stop Shop and
then last couple of bullet points
um yeah September 14 Xbox Live Gold
members will automatically become Game
Pass core members with no change in
pricing all right then member deals and
discounts will also be part of Game Pass
core games with gold will come to an end
September 1st and then yeah that's
pretty much it so attic I know you had a
lot of thoughts about this a lot of a
lot of discussion
okay yeah all right so um uh okay your
thoughts on Game Pass core okay um from
what I hear it sucks uh because it takes
away uh fundamentally something that's
supposed to be there whatever I'm a Game
Pass ultimate dude
um
this really doesn't affect me but if
you're doing tears you're not supposed
to be taking away something from one
tear uh that's you know like you know
you have something that's a base right
and then the next hair that's up should
have plus more and then a tear higher
than that should have more and that's
how tears work it's not this tier has
that and then this tear costs more but
has less that's kind of crazy this is
what I'm hearing from it I really didn't
pay too much uh mine to this uh because
again I'm a Game Pass ultimate um
subscriber and I've been doing so for a
long period of time
uh I felt that they should have
Consolidated gold a long time ago and I
think they didn't know how to do it uh
to roll it in and if this is your answer
to it
um it's two cantankerous you might have
to scale it back uh to get a better
consensus on how to roll it out we
already know that
um we pay for multiplayer
right and you know the PC player doesn't
a lot of the console players are upset
that they feel that the PC player is
getting a better deal and paying less
than uh what we are and we're footing
the um holding the line for those guys
for better uh for uh lack of a better
term
and I see that to be true
but I also feel that whenever that
you're at a deficit inside a market you
must use whatever you whatever is
necessary to gain Market penetration all
right
um so if you choose and you see that the
PC is the better option for yourself as
far as uh you know Game Pass goes and
you know by all means go to PC right
there's there's nothing preventing you
from going to get a PC and going to do
that you want equal opportunity on both
sides of the board but you're not
willing to go purchase a PC uh to do so
right you can't screen for equality and
not willing to make that happen if you
don't like your treatment in one spot
abandon that spot and go to the place
where the treatment is better if you
feel that the treatment is better here
abandon here show them that this is not
working out for me but I'll be over here
and you're not willing to do that all
you're willing to do is complain willing
to complain and talk about mistreatment
you can't have it both ways so wait I
just want to clarify you you're saying
for the The Game Pass console guy
because I think a bit of the debate is
that the Game Pass console tier doesn't
have online multiplayer right right
whereas the quote-unquote lowers here
right right which is Game Pass core does
have it but without the phone so you're
saying if you're a console guy you feel
disrespected for that then you vote with
your wallet and then go just leave just
leave but you won't do it because you're
so used to complaining and going through
the things normally and this is the sad
part of what we have going on now you
guys are not revolutionary
you're just talking to talk right do it
get rid of your Xbox and go to your PC
there's nothing stopping you go get a
rug right go get game pass over there
you're not paying for uh uh multiplayer
over there and then you have all those
games right but you won't do it you'll
just talk about it because you want to
get into our spaces or you want to get
on the Twitter feed and you want to rant
and you want to Rave and you want
somebody else to do it for you you want
somebody else to push the uh the
narrative for you but what you're going
to say is King we all should be equal
that's not how it happens over here is a
closed ecosystem and they can control
this they can't control that over on PC
so what they have to do on PC if they
have to get in where they fit in so if
it's going to be a better deal over
there because people look at Steam and
be like the steam is cracking what makes
me think I might need your your game
pass ultimate over you won't need it so
you have to show that deal you have to
show the diversity over there so I
understand what's going on over there I
don't want a game on my PC even though I
have ultimate I have the option to do so
but now that I have my Rog the ability
to do so let's makes it more versatile
that's the versatility that I have with
ultimate so I'm not looking at them
bottom tiers but if you are looking at
those bottom tiers and you feel that
you're being treated unequally I will
tell you to abandon there and go to
where you feel that you're treated best
because this is your dollar right so
stop stop getting smacked in the face
stop it now take your Xbox down to
GameStop or or put it on yeah
and sell it or trade it to somebody for
a PC and have a wonderful life playing
on PC and don't complain that's it but
I'm not gonna listen to you complaining
about you being treated wrong because
you're not being treated wrong you like
it you'll stay there you don't like it
you'll leave all right all right I'll
jump in because I had to go and last
um this one I'll be honest I heard about
it for a little bit and I was surprised
that it got as much backlash as it did
but my mentality is different and look I
don't want to be taking part I want to
be disrespectful to the console guy
because the console guy is like hey you
know this tier is you know less featured
like if you if you put them all next to
each other it looks like a tier system
that's going from lowest to highest but
for me I don't look at it like that
because to me
Game Pass gold
is was always a separate thing Game Pass
goal like forget about all these tears
right it was hey you want to play online
you got to get get you got to get um
XBox Live gold right and we'll give you
these two games per month you know for
free just bonus for the right to play
you as a bonus for paying for our
service right then it was Game Pass came
out right yo all these first party games
so to me the user had to say hey I'm on
go I play online right and I want this
game passing I'm gonna pay for gold and
I'm gonna pay for game pack you're
paying two things yeah for the right to
do what you want to do now if you want
to get into the philosophical aspect of
should people be paying for online I I
won't fight you I won't fight you that
is a completely separate thing the way I
look at it is that Xbox let's be this is
where the hustle and it's all full
because it's our fault because when Xbox
Live debuted in 2001 or whatever it
debuted right we said oh wow that is so
cool we could put a broadband connection
in the back and we can talk to our
friends I'm willing to pay for that I
was an Xbox Live Alpha tester I was like
this is great king is home addict is
home solve is at his house off I pay
this to get dressed
bro we fell for the banana in the town
pipe early so they got all lists of
revenue for all of these years of dudes
paying for this right so this is how I
look at this is not a corporate car they
are not going to be like out of the
kindness of our hearts we are going to
stop letting you pay because you know PC
is over there and now we're gonna lose
all this this check that's been coming
for impetus we're gonna say no check for
the good of the people we're gonna give
you this it's not how it works so it's
either two options here because I think
I know where addict's going right to
solve addicts problems I know what I
think I know where ad is going but he'll
explain when it's his turn is that
addicts like bro when you look at this
this is less value if I'm a core dude
right and I try to go up to um console
right I'm getting less features right
the way they look at it is they want you
an ultimate let's just be real let's
just call it let's just corporations Go
corporate they want you or here's the
real deal here's the real deal
and I think addict may agree with me I
don't know let's be real dated when Game
Pass started to cook
they like that Xbox Live Gold guy still
messing around out here whatever the
percentage of the power let's just say
it was seven I'm making up numbers Xbox
I don't know let's just say with 70 of
these dudes who just saw gold who pick
up Call of Duty and batted in 2K every
year that's it they just won't play all
out right right so they like nah we
gotta get him into Gamepad remember when
they aggressively tried to pull gold
everybody's like oh hell no Xbox this
ain't it right so they like okay Dad we
can't do that they like that right yeah
they're gonna fight that so what they're
gonna do is they gonna say okay
look for the actual if you look at it
from The Gold Guys perspective he is
cooking nothing has changed all that's
changed is his name he went from going
against my Live Gold to Xbox Live cool
right to Game Pass call right now he
gets not only ability to play online for
the same but let's be real they'll get
them Xbox Live games with gold is is dog
water like we knock on them can we be
honest
at one point they were decent less
people
right at one point and Xbox was battling
they just threw a Game Pass Jersey on
that dude you're gonna be Game Pass
right so you're gonna count towards
these numbers that we need that let's be
real this is Game Pass Jersey time
you're gonna win I know you resisted but
you go away in this jersey and guess
what nothing gonna change we're going to
keep the price to say and we're gonna
give you this this little little Buffet
you know what I'm saying
you were all this you know what I'm
saying whatever and look at the look at
the titles on this list it's funny like
some of them all right Halo Wars Twitter
down fall out like hellblade one you
like hellblade because you know the two
is coming right you know what I'm saying
then we got like a lot of these games
with sequels Forza Horizon four right
great A lot of these games are great
value and dope games now Elder Scrolls
Online all stuff that may be on the
fence and you're going to give them a
variety game but the key is see that's
the key When September come around
hey you see you record dude you were
cool you're a gold dude that got
transformed the car and you like yeah
I'm not I'm not really paying for Game
Pass like I'm here for online but you're
friendless got that Starfield you're
friendless got that force of Motorsport
you're friendless you see all and
they're like yeah but just just for like
a dollar two more you can just go up the
ultimate and you got it all family this
is the hustle this is this is the is it
it's a drug dealers this is a hustle I'm
not even going for it is I don't think I
do at this girl but I know what they're
doing they gotta transform you into Game
Pass and get the numbers up so that they
can get more games to track more
Publishers to the platform that's that's
the part I was about yeah that's what
this is I mean when PlayStation did it
nobody cried right because they get they
gave they joined and they rolled the
PlayStation Now into PlayStation Plus
and it happened I get you but to addicts
Point PlayStation PlayStations
tier system is is it's really a tier
system yeah it's real with Xbox let's be
real Xbox has always been Daniel is gold
and paid for Game Pass right that's what
it's been and let's be super real
Xbox was charging
for the free to play at one point people
had to push back how come it's free to
play but I still gotta have gold and New
Freedom right so so that's what it is so
then they got rid of that right that
that was too egregious so they got rid
of that so that's what I think it is I
just think that and and the final point
I'll give it to Alex I know you're gonna
go in is
the argument you can say that is pro
Xbox and maybe addict doesn't agree with
it a lot but it at least on Xbox you
could say
hey
I don't care about
online multiplayer right
you get Game Pass console all I'm here
is for the game I don't care I don't
want to play with others whatever
whatever and then the second one is for
the guy who's the opposite right who's
just like look I'm just here for online
I don't really care about I want to buy
my games when they come out I want to
pay my 70 I don't want to do your star
field netflixy thing or whatever you're
doing
I'll be here on the core level so at
least with them they do have the option
to choose which type of guy you own you
can make the argument that you have more
choice of what type of gamer you are but
to addicts point and I feel him I know
he's gonna go and I think I know he's
good is that when you put out the chart
and you see that in the middle and it
looked like you getting a less feature
as a Game Pass console the Optics are
bad and that doesn't sit well with
people when they look at the list long
term so the question I have added I'm
gonna give it to him is if they do what
I think you may want which is like yo
give the console Guy online multiplayer
I guess my question is would you be
willing for the overall prices to go up
because then in my opinion they're not
just going to give that away after being
able to hustle for so long on Console
God's plan so I'm curious I want to know
your answer
I mean the prices already went up okay
Game Pass already went up a Dollar too
yeah so it's like you you you raised it
for no value at that point just just
because of you know cost of inflation or
anything yeah my my issue is is just the
weird
the way this is structured first off is
only a dollar between regular Game Pass
and Game Pass core and it's just like so
it's like I said on kiss moves uh on
planet Xbox like you know what that that
animal game whatever it was at right now
I I don't know what it's called Primo or
something yeah yeah exactly so you're a
core member and you're just playing this
uh you know Call of Duty with your
friend and you're all right you know
people talk about this oh you'll just
upgrade the dollar more you'll be able
to play this game then they download it
then they're getting into it it's like
oh we want five extra dollars if you
want to play online you're like but I
was just playing online like five
minutes
they're gonna be like yo get that
ultimate fire for the five dollars and
it's just like regardless if this is a
hustle or not I'm not gonna just bend
over and say it's okay it's just like at
the end of the day like if they're going
to structure this people say attic it's
it's Games with Gold they just change
the name yeah they changed the name and
made it into a structure system even the
chart is a structure system you don't
have it core it's like it's like the
Elite control I don't have it with me
it's like the elite controller they
named The Elite control part two they
named it core for a reason because it's
the standard Elite controller and you
could buy the extra stuff if you want to
so you can go into the core the core
membership and you get online but you
upgrade and lose online feature like and
to me then that means they're putting
way more value on Ultimate like
shouldn't the fact that you have EA play
on there you have uh you have the cloud
computing on there shouldn't that sell
that more so it's like are they putting
more Spotlight on the online than there
are actually everything else like you
shouldn't
sorry I just one question and I think I
can solve your argument
should online be on all the tears then
yes that's what he wants I know that's
what he wants the moment the moment you
popped in see you have the core the only
reason that core has online is because
they can't convert people and blues
if they were able to because it's
probably illegal to take stuff away from
people and switch you because what
they're doing is they they they're doing
the the switching role they sell
PlayStation do it and then okay let's do
that because PlayStation artificially
bumped up their numbers it's our turn we
doing it now and they can't just take
away an online infrastructure like that
that people because I think legally
because we have it with patreon if we
switch a patreon here and we take stuff
away from yeah patreon makes these get
rid of the tier facts yep you legally
can't take away something legally you
can't do it so you know what they're
gonna do we're gonna make it a core
entry position you know what we're gonna
put in there we're gonna we're we're
gonna and I think this is the right
direction for switching and getting rid
of the uh Games with Gold I mean getting
rid of Xbox Live Gold in general it's
just it's just the it's the marketing
behind it it's like I said like you're
going to be marketing these high
infrastructure
multiplayer game pass games that's not
in the core subscription service and
you're gonna have these people
core
of access and let's say that okay I
don't I don't want to pay 60 for the
animal dinosaur game
I'm gonna go back and just play Call of
Duty guess what they already switched up
so when they go to play Call of Duty
with their friends that they just play
30 minutes ago
we want you to backpedal to a one that
you just went for and pays less money
and you want us to either Pace a dollar
less
to to go back to online or we want five
more dollars for you to continue to play
online
it's not the right it's not the right
it's it's not the right movement
it's very predatorial I'm gonna be real
with you they they're deliberately
making something look like more value
but they're taking away the most biggest
thing that's in it but wait hold on it's
not predatorial for the game pass the
Xbox Gold guy the goal if you're just a
gold guy that guy is winning he's
getting it all I just want to be clear
on that part I I have no predatory on
the go God because the go guy is the one
that's gonna have to train and switch up
he never had the option
they're putting you in a situation where
they're thinking you're gonna actually
Captivate they're gonna put something
like this dino game in there and you
feel like okay I'm gonna I'm gonna break
the dollar and I'm gonna play this and
then they hit that okay now not only you
paying the dollar you paying the other
five on top
you can switch back to what you just had
and play Call of Duty
it doesn't make sense I'm gonna give you
pushback If I Was A Game's gold dude and
I wasn't looking at Game Pass anyway he
it ain't lit none of that stuff mattered
to me yeah
you're upgrade to go play see you're
giving fake scenarios no but it's not a
fake scenario the majority of the game
will go do the majority of the people on
games on Xbox Live gold right now is a
lot of the Casual audience that's why
they never switch because they'd only
want to play 2K
they are setting a a piece of cheese in
front of them putting them over that's
giving that's not predatory they're
giving more value but the thing is
they're setting this cheese and like yo
come over here and play these extra
games
so so they're going over there and this
is not a fake scenario the majority of
these people don't want to play these
games that's why they're putting them in
the court they've been in the Xbox Live
Gold for years right so they're like
okay come and play this dinosaur game or
whatever it's called EXO prime or
something yeah okay I'll give you the
extra dollar and then they're like okay
I'm not paying 60 for that I I don't
want to do that I'm gonna go back and
play what I was playing so then they're
like okay you gave us the extra dollar
and now the game that you actually play
on our Xbox we want an extra five or you
want to have to go back to the previous
year you was in or you can't even play
that no but what previous tier gold you
know either once you're in Game Pass
goal a Game Pass uh cool because gold is
just
to Game Pass so if you're a person that
plays Call of Duty every year and your
fans jump in the park like yo let's play
this this actually still gonna play Call
of Duty okay let me jump over that and
try it so you get over there and you
play that in the regular game pass at
this point and it says yo if you want to
play online you got to give us an extra
five dollars on top of the one that
you've already gave us to upgrade from
court to regular games
the discrepancy is that guy was buying
Call of Duty for seventy dollars
regardless he was gonna play online with
gold regardless he was never but my
point is you've got that dude to switch
because he wasn't him
listening to you but it's like it's
don't be done because it's a
conversation that you're having but
you're not trying to I'm gonna finish
so you you give this person
let's play this EXO Primal they're in it
because they want to play Call of Duty
but they're willing to try another game
okay I'll give you this extra dollar so
they go over there and like yo if you
want to play online with uh Primal you
have to pay the extra five to go to
Ultimate or you got to go back to the
previous tier where you were so they're
like okay I don't want to do that that's
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna go play
Call of Duty because I don't want to pay
extra money to do that but then they
they boot up Call of Duty and it asks
for that again
if you because once you go back because
they're going to go back and play the
game that they're originally playing
which is cod Madden 2K right and now
that they've got them to upgrade for
this game that they can't play because
they can't play online in the middle
tier they're either gonna have to go up
to Ultimate to play Call of Duty again
or they have to go right back down to
core to play Call of Duty again
I'm confused because Game Pass they
won't be able to play EXO Primal or Call
of Duty if they were Xbox Live Gold guy
that could got converted to core they
can't play that game so they were going
to buy 70 let's play the game and have
the online version as a core guy that
that the only temptation is if they see
EXO Primal and they see Call of Duty as
part of Game Pass but their game pass
core they have a curated list that is
only these games and that's it they
can't do Starfield they can't do it the
hope of Xbox is the hope that they
upgrade to to that now if you saying
they upgrade you know will they upgrade
to
um to console Xbox console that's
different because then if you upgrade to
Xbox console you lose the ability to go
online my assumption or I'm sure that
assumption but what I would think
Microsoft would do is say hey you're a
core guy
go to Ultimate right so you're I know
what you're argument your argument is
the upgrade path right and then right it
isn't right because you give people the
scenario like because like I said
there's a reason these people ain't on
Game Pass right they're mainly playing
just the same games right absolutely I
get your points
I got you now and then they get in that
tier they're gonna pay more about to
play these games I gotta try to play
these games online and then they go to
play the first online game in game
package when you go up they're not going
to tell you what you lose I guarantee
you if you switch from core to Game Pass
then I could say yeah you better lose
online your question is is Court will
Game Pass console even be an option for
a core guy and will it be well that's
the question right but but here's the
point that's on that chart let me give
it to you very specifically I think I'm
sorry I can't finish
my my issue with it is once you're in
that middle tier
and you're wanting to play something in
that game pass you either have to go up
like there's no there's no getting
anything separate like when you go from
that middle tier to play some of that
first chair play something in that
middle here if you want to play online
you have to upgrade again or up or or
downgrade back to the original one so
there
look sure people could go back down but
most of the time they're going to get
that dollar from whoever wants to
upgrade to the game pass and then go get
that extra five if they want to play
caller most of these people I did I did
call service for two years at Dish
Network most these people ain't really
educating none of this matter they're
gonna upgrade they're gonna upgrade
every time they're gonna be some people
that gets upset go back down but my
point is you giving people the option to
upgrade to play a game that you have
promoted as a multiplayer game you're in
that core membership but you know once
they upgrade they won't have access to
that game online now if they upgrade to
Game Pass console yes
now okay I'm gonna give it to you I know
the thing is this
and I think this is where our disconnect
is is that
they know from their analytics and their
metrics and their Telemetry The Game
Pass gold the Xbox Live Gold guy was not
moving he was not tempted by Game Pass
he was not moving so they transformed
him into Game Pass core and he's got
better value and in their mind they're
like yo you could stay there you can you
haven't shown that you're willing to
move nothing that game pass does is
enticing you you're cool with paying for
getting seventy dollars and playing for
online and we're happy that you're there
we're just changing your name we're
giving you a jersey nothing's changing
and I think that's how they're resolving
it they're like look we're not gonna
move that guy off his Square he hasn't
moved for all these years so that's what
it is but that's what I thought that
King I'm gonna let you finish then we
can move on but all right
um I go to Taco Bell
every week every week I get two cheesy
bean burritos
two cheesy bean burritos is the cheapest
thing on the menu
doesn't have any meat just have bean
cheese and rice okay I can work with
that
Game Pass that's the whole menu That's
the smorgasbord you can get everything
if I wanted to go in there and get a
Cheesy Bean Crunchwrap Supreme it'll
cost me extra money I can do that
the game's a gold dude it's me cheesy
cheesy Bean dude I can see whatever the
hell you have up there I don't care what
my who's in the car getting what who's
upgrading to what I don't care I'm
getting my cheesy bee in the mouth and
nothing on your menu is gonna entice me
Game Pass look that deck Microsoft
looked at them was like yo these dudes
are never coming over man and the
numbers is consistent this guy goes out
he spends his money for Forza whatever
the hell whatever the hell he spends his
money on he or she they stay there and
that's it
I don't see because you you made uh
a scenario an assumption
that that guy that got converted from
gold into core is going to be enticed by
anything he hasn't been enticed by
anything ever so why would he be entice
just because they changed his name right
and I don't think that's a valid reason
to have the argument but I must say this
online should be available in all in
fact that's the issue here that's the
big issue here that's what we all agree
on right it's the online console guy
yeah dude that's in core that dude that
was gold
he's always gonna be gold he's all you
just changed his name he don't he's he
doesn't care if Starfield is coming out
because he wasn't playing that anyway he
was going to go get his way I'm gonna
call my man we're Frodo at the chat he a
gold dude put your hand up code I want
to know how this affects you because
this really he's a guy that will refuse
to buy gay fast I'm sorry okay I see you
it's just the fact that I think it's
disingenuous to assume that the core the
games of gold bless you the game's a
gold dude who is now a core dude just
because he got his name changed is now
going to have a different appetite for
other games I don't believe that that to
be true I believe that that person is
going to be core and he's going to stay
core and probably don't even be enticed
by anything that's inside Game Pass core
that will just continue to just do his
online stuff just to play online stuff
or whatever and play those games that he
normally plays he or she whatever but I
feel that fundamentally as a business
practice core has online the middle test
should have online
I think we're all in agreement there and
I think that's why to attic's point
there is a a slight problem with the
messaging and confusion like that middle
team when you look at it across the
board yes my whole point is just to
justify that that middle tier should be
online regardless right absolutely I
know where you're going brother the
point is is if you offer a tier system
people in the chat saying this isn't a
tearsome yes it is they want you to go
from the core system to either to the
middle or get Game Pass ultimate they're
not going to offer you the the PC thing
that's just saying that that's existing
this is definitely a tier system there's
no way around that
I don't think it's a tier system but I
do understand the point of being a Xbox
console guy not having online seems
weird that's just the bottom line it's
just weird and it's something that we as
console Gamers should have never signed
the blood Money contract but we we got
listen it was at its time it was
revolutionary nobody was doing it you
know we thought how great they they put
I always give Xbox credit for um
pioneering the Broadband era into the
space the ethernet in the back of the OG
Xbox I was an Xbox Live Alpha tester I
thought that was the greatest thing to
be able to talk to someone in Australia
who never met me before and we're
playing Ghost Recon and I'm like yo this
is amazing from that point on everybody
adopted it PlayStation started charging
Nintendo now does this thing so again
not saying it's right
and to King's Point though King got I
think had one of the strongest points
out of all of us
the problem is console dudes just talk
and King is right if if you truly put
your foot down because according to Xbox
they want you over that's the most
closest PC
so dudes be talking that's a completely
different argument in itself true the
fact that it that line between a PC Xbox
ecosystem in an Xbox like the console
Xbox system keeps getting bigger and
bigger first it was a little bit of time
exclusives now that you don't have to
play online and then it's EA play is
in-game pass for PC but not Game Pass
for console and then on top of that you
pay five dollars less to be in PC game
pass when you do console Game Pass yeah
and that's the thing and I think they
know the PC guy I mean excuse me the
console guy doesn't want to buy a PC and
the PC guys content where he over there
and that's why we're in the situation
yeah PC thing Microsoft should be
ashamed of himself for doing no they
don't they should do exactly what
they're doing yeah
I'm a consumer first
me too and like apparently not like you
don't care about the concert I don't
care
my PC my PC is right there if I want to
get busy with my PC pause I will get 50
with my pieces I don't like my PC that
like what what in your personal opinion
what is more
of value PC game pass or console games
it depends on the individual yeah
five dollars less okay time out time out
you're gonna ask me
I play on my console
the PC can burn to the ground for all I
care I don't care about PC game pass and
I don't care what exclusive games they
got popping off over there I don't care
to look inside there to figure it out
what I do care about is when I go turn
on my Xbox series X that I paid that 500
for that the games in there is on there
that's it and don't tell me about old PC
then they got something Skylanders too I
don't care like I'm just it's just me
but it's an option
come over and do it you don't feel a way
that PC game pass pays less for what you
pay for oh I don't know about the same
you know what it is I don't care about
what somebody else doing my like my
mentality is not about what somebody but
you're paying me but they're often
different consumers the same product is
you at a cheaper price I have ultimate
if I choose to partake I can do so that
gives me versatility now what you're
trying to tell me is you know the PC guy
I have a PC guy uh shout out to a big
fat Eli he plays on his PC inside of his
country because financially it's it's
just it just works that way for him
right and he's able to be a little bit
more versatile in doing so and it works
for him
I can't begrudge him for for uh the fact
that he doesn't pay for online I don't
even know what his infrastructure is
over there but my thought is if I did
have a problem with it my series X my
series s's that's all over the place
they'll be gone and I just game on this
bad boy right here I don't care to do so
I'm not I don't envy what the PC people
are saving in their five dollars because
what they what also goes along with that
is I gotta update these drivers on my PC
I gotta go on my PC and do all this
other stuff that I don't care to do I
like to turn on my Xbox and it works so
if that five dollars is a convenience to
me that I feel that that five dollars is
well spent in that convenience in that
ecosystem then I'm going to game there
that's why you don't hear me screaming
about this but you do hear me screaming
that that middle tear should have online
and I think fundamentally we all can
agree the problem is that they don't
offer online in that middle tier to hell
with what the PC dude is doing because
I'm trust me I'm telling you I get
disgusted when I'm playing fortnite and
I see a little PC pop up in the corner I
was playing on it because I know it's
going to be a problem
I'm sorry you you can feel that way
that's fine that's just something we're
gonna have to agree to disagree because
I don't like it I don't like the fact
that they try to sell us the same
product essentially for for me right I
mean but but I don't have to boycott
something not to like it I can do both
oh
no that's fair look that's fair I think
that um you know addict's making a good
point as far as your online thing I
think that's the fundamental issue I
think King's making a good point about
the convenience of console versus the PC
guy why people still stay in the uh the
console ecosystem versus the PC guy that
is to put the entry points to Costa we
could go on and on for that but I do
agree that the for us to have this
discussion about a chart means that
there is somewhat of a messaging thing
that could be addressed as far as yeah I
think that's the online part is is the
is the messaging on this particular
problem but for me I do want to defend
on one last point before we go I do feel
that it is not I want to just be clear
on my part with this I don't feel it's
predatory for the Xbox Live Gold guy
that guy is getting a way better deal
than he ever had before I just wanted to
stress that guy because if I whatever
the metrics are I don't know what the
splits are 70 30 you know but they want
to convert that guy and this was the way
to get him in and then ultimately this
is the way long term to say hey third
party company we have a hundred you know
instead of you know 30 million Game Pass
subscribers we have with this 70 100
million now that that goes to the
business model right that that's
ultimately what they're trying to do and
that's I think that's where we're at but
it behooves Microsoft at some point
maybe to look at what I would say which
is The Game Pass console guy and why you
know he has it and then have those
important conversations that if we if
they do include online multiplayer
what the price is going to be because my
opinion they're not giving that a free
they're going I don't think they're
doing anything to be honest with you
they may not if they were wanting to do
anything they would have did it when
they did the structure of Tears system
they didn't so I have no intentions if
they'll ever fix this and and
unfortunately it made a point and to
your point that's a good point there and
to King's Point you know it puts the
pressure on the onus on the consumer to
say you know what I don't like that
right I don't like that this is
predatory I feel this this other tier is
not giving me good value I'm out it puts
the bonus on that person to do that so
it's a good discussion though I do like
this let us get these super chats and